je vous le dis franchement comme
d'habitude je ne crois pas vraiment en
résultat de cette rencontre mais il faut
tout essayer
pour qu'aucun ukrainien n'est le moindre
doute que j'ai tout tenté en tant que
président afin de mettre fin à la guerre
quand tu nous opportunité même minuscule
s'est présenté
voilà pour cette déclaration donc de
volo Dimir Zelinski et Gauthier vinsky
vous êtes toujours avec nous avec nous
en plateau on l'a entendu le président
ukrainien il l'a dit je vous dis
franchement je ne crois pas vraiment aux
résultats de cette rencontre donc
qu'est-ce qu'il qu'est-ce qu'il dit
qu'est-ce qu'il attend peut-être de ces
de ces pour parler peut-être devoir tout
simplement
lui ce qui peut attendre c'est pour
parler c'est éventuellement une forme de
répit très provisoire très momentané
dans les combats encore que
il va faire peu de chances pour que ça
se réalise mais il le dit lui-même il le
dit pour que aucun
ukrainien ne puisse penser que je n'ai
pas tout tenté mais dans la logique
ukrainienne à la fois politique qui est
celle de résister mais à la fois
personnel imaginez-vous Zelinski qui a
souvent été moqué parce que c'est un
acteur parce que c'est un comique à
l'origine
j'allais dire mais c'est pas méchamment
c'est pas méchant ce que je vais dire
c'est qu'il tient en quelque sorte le
rôle de sa vie sauf que c'est un rôle
tout à fait sérieux et réel et que dans
ce cadre-là on ne voit pas comment étant
donné l'état d'esprit aussi des
Ukrainiens il y aurait vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure aucune velléité de
reddition aucune volonté de capitulation
et qu'à partir de ce moment-là d'une
certaine manière on peut dire que il y a
comment dire ça il y a des héros qui se
découvrent au gré des circonstances des
gens qui n'étaient pas préparés à l'être
ou qu'il n'était pas préparé à avoir des
idées politiques qui se retrouvent la
voir parce que les circonstances le
veulent il me semble qu'en ce qui
concerne le président
ukrainien on est typiquement dans ce cas
de figure